when the rock won the Debbie w/e
championship in 2013 he wanted a custom
belt this video is about the guy who
made that belt this is Dave Milliken the
industry leader in championship belt
making he's also a huge wrestling fan
yep that sounds about right
he's been in the business for a while
since he was a little kid I was 13 when
I made my first belt and it was really
bad the guy who made belts before David
was this guy
Reggie Parkes taking me under his wing
had everything to do with my development
even my initial respect in this business
one of veterans
everybody knew Reggie Parkes nobody knew
Dave Milliken and here's how they're
made step 1 artwork step 2 edging step 3
would be the bolt work step 4
plating and then from there you pretty
much have a complete belt although some
have paint some don't have paint it
varies from designed it's done in each
belt is unique in its own way I've
actually been asked how many belts left
made by now we're more in the thousands
believe it or not the WWE isn't his
biggest client right now
somebody'd orders just as many belts as
lip sync battle television but we're
here for wrestling nostalgia countless
stars ranging from stone coal to John
Cena himself have worn Dave's belts it's
certainly a labor of love as some of
these belts can take up to a year to
finish which makes the question which
one is his favorite asking me my
favorite belts like asking me to pick my
favorite kid that would be a lot of kids
to have to choose from
[Music]
in the dressing room something happens
while I'm getting ready once I start
putting my makeup on I turn from this
male to female and that is amazing for
me
[Music]
my name is Cassandra luxottica
I am a professional wrestler I've been
wrestling for 28 years I'm an exotic
Oulu teller which is a flamboyant
wrestler with glamour and style
[Music]
[Applause]
I always knew I was different I remember
when I was in second grade I think I was
like 7 or 8 years old and I already knew
I was I was gay I was taught that I
couldn't be gay I couldn't act this way
I couldn't dress this way I couldn't
talk this way because I was gonna burn
in hell when I was first called to be an
exotic car I was like wow freedom this
weighted that I've been carrying for
years was just like melted down
rhinestones down glow-in-the-dark I
started using the panty hose the makeup
the bathing suits rhinestone feathers
and Boas and all that because I wanted
to be different and that was the
scariest moment but when I saw the
audience and the fans how they took me
in they were just like wow look at him
her.she I feel like a woman inside and
then it's like
and that transformation is beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
something happens when I get out of the
dressing room to the ring I'm still
looking like a woman I'm looking
flamboyant and then once I step in the
ring my macho sigh kicks in I might
better be ready for the fight all my
cuddle matches and mostly all of our
matches have been against men
masked man like cheese stars homophobe
eggs and I've always been true to myself
it's Lucha Libre you're not a beauty
parlor even though it looks like it
sometimes today I can tell you that
being gay has been a gift from God to me
and I understand that so that's why you
Charlie very has always been one of my
biggest medications I don't think I will
ever leave me calibrate this is what
I've done all my life
[Music]
assumer s lien is a game of seconds
[Music]
however there's months of training that
go within those seconds imagine it's
like an earthquake that's building and
building and building and all of a
sudden there's this huge explosion all
at one time
that's what Singh was I'm really just a
normal guy I'm a husband I'm a father of
three I'm the director of technology for
the County Office of Education I'm also
an American soon we're outside
Summa has a long history in Japan some
people trace it back up to 1500 or 2000
years but it's essentially you know
wrestling where you either want to push
your opponent out of the ring
or knock your opponent to the ground
people have an image that sumo wrestlers
are basically just bumping bellies and
wobbling around and as you can see from
the practice here nothing's further from
the truth
Roy is amazing he basically came out of
nowhere he showed up to the 2014 US sumo
open and blew everyone's mind he beat
every single American opponent with
almost no training he's already the
number one American to be a competitive
sumo wrestler you need to train hard
whether I'm stretching with them
powerlifting where that I'm working out
with with rocks I'm always looking for
the edge the thing that really brought
me to sumo was the fact that there was
culture and sport all kind of mixed in
one it seemed like a perfect fit for
example when you stomp the ground you're
ridding the area of bad spirits and when
you make your first clap you're waking
up the gods you know he is a gentle
giant and he doesn't want to hurt
anybody and sumos great that way because
you know and they just trying to get
each other out of the ring they're not
trying to knock each other out or really
hurt hurt one another
I think sumo has a camaraderie
fraternity aspect to it
you know we're banging heads we're going
at it at the end of it there's still
this higher level of respect
I guess as a pacifist that definitely
appeals to me when I tell people that
I'm a wrestler if they don't really
believe me at first I don't know what
image they have in their head of what a
wrestler should look like
especially when I say I'm the super
heavyweight for women's wrestling and
they're like you wrestle like you're
you're kind of too pretty to wrestle and
so it's always interesting to me cuz I'm
like what did you expect my name is
adilyn gray I'm a three-time world
champion ranked number one in the world
been undefeated for two and a half years
and I'm gonna compete in the Rio Olympic
Games in August I never really
considered the Olympics as an option for
me when I was younger kid and it's
something that I don't think enough
girls have an opportunity to dream about
[Music]
I want to redefine feminine to some
extent and and to have people challenge
the way they look at the word strong and
not just see a boy that pops into your
head
I started wrestling boys I was six years
old and I wrestled boys all the way
through high school and I think I earned
a lot of respect from a lot of the the
teammates out there who did lose to me
or maybe beat me and I got to train with
the best guys in the world and they made
me tougher they made me work for every
single point I had to wrestle with and
and they made it so that I could be a
champion on the women's level now we
teach girls to be perfect and boys to
take risks I need to take risks that I
am a confident strong female who knows
that I'm great at wrestling I'm still
struggling with that concept that I'm
worried about not being perfect when I
step on the mat
[Music]
I have to step on that mat and make sure
that I work every single moment to win
an Olympic gold medal I want young girls
to be able to look at thatmy situation
and be able to dream about it I'm
excited for that moment to have my flag
risen and and be able to know that I'm
gonna hold a gold medal around my neck
you
[Music]
you